THE OTHER BILLS AND THEN WHEN
THEY LEAVE THAT EVERYBODY CAN
COME INTO THOSE FIRST TWO ROWS.
AS WELL JUST SO FOLKS WHO ARE
HERE FOR WE HAVE.
HOW MANY CALLS WE HAVE A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX BILLS SO THERE'S
GONNA BE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO
BE HERE TO SPEAK ON THOSE HO
AND?
FORTY SIX SO WE CAN KEEP THE
FIRST TWO ROWS OPEN FOR THEM AND
THEN.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY EVERYBODY CAN
TAKE THOSE SPOTS WHEN PEOPLE ARE.
LEAVE AND WE DO OUR SPECIAL
ORDER SO THANK YOU
-- FIVE
THIRTEEN APPROPRIATIONS HEARING
TO ORDER AND GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
EYES ARE HERE BATES.
BATES HERE BRADFORD BRADFORD
HERE HILL.
JONES WE CAL SKI HERE BECAUSE HE
HERE.
I WE HAVE A QUORUM -- WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FORTY SIX BILLS TO HEAR
TODAY FIVE A WHICH ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR A TO PASS.
THE REMAINING BILLS ARE ALL
SUSPENSE ITEMS -- THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ON FILE WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY SB SEVEN THREE TWO BY
MISTER ALLEN WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR.
AND SB ONE EIGHTY TWO BY MS
JACKSON AND SB TWO TEN LEYVA AND
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX ALLEN WILL BE.
SCARED RE SCHEDULED FOR LATER
THIS WEEK.
EVERYBODY GOT THAT ONE EIGHTY
TWO TO TEN AND FIVE TWENTY SIX
LATER THIS WEEK WE ALSO HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS TODAY --
TO HEAR SB TWO SEVEN SIX BY
DOCTOR PAN THE MEASURE WILL BE
TAKEN UP AFTER WE FINISH THE
REST THE BUSINESS.
AS A REMINDER I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE OUR MESSAGE TO THE
AUDIENCE AND MEMBERS THE
TESTIMONY TODAY.
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO THE FISCAL
IMPACTS OF THE BILL WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD OR OTHER POLICY
COMMITTEES OF ALREADY HEARD
THESE BILLS AND POLICY COMMITTEE.
SO PLEASE BRING YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THIS GOES TO ALL BILLS AND
ALL OF TESTIMONY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE OFFERING
TESTIMONY PLEASE REFRAIN FROM
LIFE THE POLICY DISCUSSIONS IN
YOUR COMMENTS AND TESTIMONY.
AND WE THE SERGEANTS.
I KNOW SENATOR NIELSEN HERE
YOU'RE CALLING THE REST OF OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND MISTER
SENATOR NIELSEN PLEASE COME ON
UP YOU WILL PRESENT YOUR BILL.
HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
THERE IS YOU ARE PRESENTING SB.
THREE EIGHTY TWO I WHICH IS A TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND HAS
SUPPORT AND SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES.
SO PLEASE TELL US ABOUT SB.
THREE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I WISH YOU
FORTY TWO THIS ARGUES DAY.
ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS.
ENCOUNTERS DISASTERS OF BERRIEN
SOURCE.
OBVIOUSLY I'M NO STRANGER. TO
SUCH INCLUDING ONE OF THE WORST.
DURING THESE TIMES ARE HOSPITALS.
COME TO THE FORE TO BE HELPFUL.
BOTH WITHIN THE AREA OF
DISASTERS AND IN MANY CASES SUCH
AS PARADISE WHERE THE HOSPITAL
WAS [inaudible]
DISABLED.
THEY HELP THEIR FELLOW HOSPITALS
[inaudible]
IT'S CRITICAL.
AND THESE SMALLER HOSPITALS
PARTICULARLY.
BLACK RESOURCES EVEN IN THE GOOD
TIMES [inaudible]
AND IT'S DEALING WITH THE HIGHER
LEVELS OF CARE.
OUR OUR GREATEST NEED.
THE HEALTH PLANS.
HAVE HAS.
HELPED THESE HOSPITALS. TO
DIRECT.
THE LOWER NEEDS [inaudible]
CARE PEOPLE. TWO OTHER PLACES.
BUT THERE INSTANCES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF USE LOOPHOLES
[inaudible] TO NEGLECT.
SHAKING IN ESTABLISHING THE CARE.
FOR THESE LOWER LEVEL HOSPITALS.
FOR THE USES OCCURRING SB.
THREE EIGHTY TWO CLARIFIES
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS.
PLANS TO ASSIST THE HOSPITAL.
IN IDENTIFYING IN TRANSFERRING
TRANSFERRING PATIENTS TO LOWER
LEVELS OF CARE.
SUCH AS SKILLED NURSING.
IF THERE'S NO OF ELEVELD
ELIGIBILITY AT THESE LARA LEVELS
OF CARE IT WOULD REQUIRE THE
HEALTH PLAN TO REAP REIMBURSE
THE HOSPITAL'S AT EXTREMELY LOW.
OR MODEST RATES. TO KEEP THOSE
PATIENTS THEN [inaudible]
IN CARE.
IT IS NOT A NEW MANDATE.
ON HEALTH PLANS.
IT IS REVENUE NEUTRAL.
IT DOES CLUES CLOSE A LOOPHOLE
DAHLE.
AND I TRULY BELIEVE.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
IN SECURING.
CONTINUED CARE. FOR THESE NEEDY
PATIENTS WE HAVE A FORMIDABLE
PHALANX OF SUPPORT HERE -- WE
WILL NOT WASTE YOUR TIME BUT IF
WE COULD PRESENT THAT WOULD
APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
RESEARCHER MEMBERS ALEX AUTHOR
IN THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WITH THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL JUST TO
REITERATE THIS ISN'T A NEW
MANDATE REQUIREMENT ON HEALTH
PLANS THIS.
SIMPLY CLARIFIES EXISTING
RESPONSIBILITIES APPRECIATE THE
FINE ANALYSIS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
RIGHT ARE THERE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
I'M SURE OPPOSITION.
FINANCE GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JULIAN A DEER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
I DON'T HAVE A FILE ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING --
ANY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU MAKE
A BRIEF CLOSER  WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE
LEGEND JEALOUS.
OF THE PANEL.
I THINK THIS IS A BIG NEED.
WE CAN ADDRESS IT.
IN A VERY [inaudible]
POSITIVE WAY.
AND WITH NO PAIN TO OUR BUDGET.
BUT WITH A LOT OF POSITIVE. FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
WE CAL SKI HI WE CASKEY AYE.
CURRENTLY FIVE ZERO WILL KEEP
THAT ON CALL.
THEY'RE VERY MUCH SIR.
THANK YOU FOR WAIVING
PRESENTATION AND THE OTHER TWO
BILLS.
SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS HERE
WILL GO TO THE TOP OF THE FILE
SB ONE SENATOR ATKINS IS A
SUSPENSE FILM.
FOR THEY HAVE BUILT OVER THE
LINE.
WE WANT TO GO MISTER HAVING TO
FIGHT WILL TAKE MISTER HEALTH.
I'M HAPPY TO DISPENSE WITH MR
HELL.
NEVER LET IT BE SAID THAT THE
CHAIR CAMP BECAUSE ALWAYS HE'S A
LEARNER.
ALWAYS PLACE TELL US ABOUT SB
SIX NINE NINE I'D BE HAPPY TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SB SIX
NINE NINE WOULD EXTEND THE
EXISTING SUNSET PROVISIONS FOR
STATE OVERSIGHT.
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S REQUIRED
CAPITAL PROGRAM FROM JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY SIX
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO EXTEND SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA REGIONAL
WATER SYSTEM FINANCING AUTHORITY.
AND AUTHORIZES THE RFA TO ISSUE
REVENUE BONDS AND TAKE OTHER
ACTIONS TO IMPROVE THE
RELIABILITY OF THE REGIONAL
WATER SYSTEM OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE HAVE
A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
BRIEFLY ALL RIGHT SHE'S ON HER
WAY.
TELL US ABOUT THIS FINE BILL BY
MY FINE COLLEAGUES.
IMMERSED MY NAME IS NICOLE
SINGLE I'M THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE BAY AREA WATER
SUPPLYING CONSERVATION AGENCY.
I REPRESENT THE TWENTY SIX WATER
SUPPLIERS IN SAN MATTEO IN
ALAMEDA AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES.
THAT SERVE ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE RESIDENTS FORTY
THOUSAND BUSINESSES AND THEY ALL
RELY ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
REGIONAL WATER SYSTEM.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO THEM
BECAUSE DIXON'S THE STATE
OVERSIGHT -- ON SAN FRANCISCO'S
IMPROVEMENTS TO THIS REGIONAL
WATER SYSTEM -- OVERSIGHT THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY PROVIDED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE
NO FILE -- ANY QUESTIONS IS
THERE MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SB SIX NINE
NINE MISTER HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE EVERY EFFORT -- MEMBERS
MY FAVORITE CLOSE WITH THAT WILL
TAKE THE VOTE.
PORTANTINO HI YOU KNOW I BATES
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
OFFERED AYE HILL.
HI HILL AYE JONES WE CAL SKI.
WE CAL SKI I WILL KEEP THAT BILL
ON CALL IT IS FIVE VOTES RIGHT
NOW MISTER BRADFORD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TELL US ABOUT SB.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FIVE
THIRTY FOUR HOUSE THREE PARTS
FIRST -- IT REESTABLISHES TO
INSURANCE REQUIRED DIVERSITY
SURVEY WHICH SUNSET ON JANUARY
ONE OF THIS YEAR -- SB FIVE
THIRTY FOR INSURERS AT THE DATA
FROM THE SURVEY CONTINUES TO BE
COLLECTED INCLUDES DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES SUCH
AS B. L. G. B. T. OWNED.
VETERAN OWNED BUSINESSES SECOND
IT CODIFIES THE GOVERNING BOARD --
DIVERSITY SURVEY DESIGNED TO
IMPROVE DIVERSITY AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF GOVERNANCE AND THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND THE THIRD
PIECE IT CODIFIES INSURANCE
DIVERSITY TASKFORCE.
THE TASK FORCE WILL BE COMPRISED
OF FIFTEEN MEMBERS APPOINTED BY
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER TO
ROUTE REPRESENT INSURANCE
COMPANIES EXPERTS IN SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY IN GOVERNING BOARD
DIVERSITY AND DIVERSE BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES -- WITH ME TODAY IS
MICHAEL GONZALEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND I
WAS REQUEST FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
PLEASE TELL US.
MORNING MIKE MARTINEZ I MEAN
MARTINEZ I AM SO SORRY MY IT'S
MONDAY MORNING.
IT'S MONDAY MORNING MONDAY
MORNING MICHAEL MARTINEZ HER
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO WATER.
PUMP SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE AND
ABSOLUTE TRUTH WHAT SENATOR
BRADFORD HAD SAID AND THIS BILL
WOULD RESULT IN MINOR COSTS TO
THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE TO
IMPLEMENT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE NO FILE
NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS FOR MISTER
BRADFORD.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE COUNTY WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK MISTER MARTINEZ
FOR BEING HERE THIS MORNING ALL
RIGHT WHAT'S CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE BATES.
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES WE CASKEY HI WE
CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS ON CALL -- FORTY
ZERO AND I SEE MISTER DODD THAT
IS IN THE ROOM PLEASE COME TELL
US ABOUT SB. TWO FORTY WHICH IS
A TO PASS WOULD SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
ORDER MISS CARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE I BOUGHT MY FAVORITE.
I LOVE IT.
TELL US.
SB TWO FORTY REQUIRES TRAINING --
FOR LICENSE INDEPENDENT
ADJUSTERS PRIOR TO REGISTERING
AS AN EMERGENCY ADJUSTER AND
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO PREPARE NOTICE --
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CALIFORNIA LAWS REGARDING
PROPERTY -- INSURANCE POLICIES
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS YEAH THIS IS
A WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
WELL SERVED AND WE HAVE A
NATURAL DISASTER NOT ENOUGH THAT --
ADJUSTERS INSTEAD OF LICENSING
ALL OF THEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE TAKEN A
DIFFERENT APPROACH WHICH WOULD
BE TO MAKE MAKE SURE THEY'VE GOT.
THE BASICS OF EDUCATION OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA LAW PERTAINING TO
INSURANCE.
THANK YOU ARE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HER BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AND TO THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE.
LET'S SEE.
FAIRLY MINIMAL COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO IMPLEMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION A CLAIMS
PROFESSIONALS AND WE ARE SUPPORT
WITH AMENDMENTS.
JUST AS SOME MIGHT MINOR
MODIFICATIONS THAT WERE WORKING
WITH STAFF ON BUT WE DO
REPRESENT THE FOLKS WHO OFTEN
HAVE TO COME IN TO CALIFORNIA ON
AN EMERGENCY BASIS IN ORDER TO
HANDLE ALL OF THE WILDFIRE
ANOTHER.
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE CLAIMS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS CONTAINED IN THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCIAL FILE NO
FILE ANY QUESTIONS FOR MISTER
DUNNE.
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MISTER DAHLE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE A CLOSE ACTUALLY ASK DR
ALL RIGHT CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
EYEING PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS FIVE OH TO TIME CALL
I AM NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS MAYES
RUBIO.
PLEASE COME UP AND TELL US ABOUT
SB FIVE SEVENTY WHICH HAS
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE -- OF
COURSE I WILL GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE.
SB FIVE SEVENTY IS A SUNSET
EXTENSION TO LOW COST AUTO
INSURANCE PROGRAM ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL WILL MAKE SEVERAL
INCREMENTAL CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM INCLUDING.
ELIMINATING A GENDER DISTINCTION
USE FOR SEARCH CHARGING RATES
ALLOWING COMMUTING STUDENTS TO
APPLY FOR COVERAGE UNDER THE
PROGRAM AND CODIFIED DEPARTMENT
REGULATIONS TO INCLUDE
EMANCIPATED SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS.
AND FINANCIALLY INDEPENDENT
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD INTO THE
PROGRAM ANY EXTRA PROGRAM
EXPENSES TO THE DEPARTMENT UNDER
SB FIVE SEVENTY SHOULD BE
ABSORBABLE.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE MICHAEL
MARTINEZ FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TRANSFER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MICHAEL MARTINEZ
HERE BEHALF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER CARD ALARM PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE NO FISCAL
COST TO THE DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENT
THANK YOU.
WE LIKE THINGS THAT HAVE NO
FISCAL CLASS.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR MS RUBIO.
WE DO HAVE A QUICK QUESTION FOR
MS BATES.
I AM A MAYBE FOR MISTER MARTINEZ
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE -- THE
PROGRAM HASN'T REALLY GROWN IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW PEOPLE FINING
ON USING IT.
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW THIS
MIGHT BE.
A BETTER OF ADVERTISE SO PEOPLE
KNOW -- IN CAN BE INSURED I'M
NOT SURE IF THE OTHER SIDE OF IT
THAT PEOPLE ARE.
YOU KNOW NOT GETTING INSURANCE
EXCEPT WHEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY
REALIZE A BETTER HAVE AND THEN
WHEN THEY SHOW THAT THEY HAVE IT
THEN THEY LET IT -- LAPS SO JUST
WONDERING WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT ARE EVEN THOUGH THERE'S NO
COST THERE CERTAINLY IS THE COST
OF THEIR AN INSURED ANDERSON.
THANK YOU RATES FOR THAT
QUESTION AND AND IT'S THAT
PARTICULAR QUESTION
STRATEGICALLY IS WHY
COMMISSIONER LOTTE IS SPONSORING
THIS MEASURE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CHAIR.
SUCH A RUBIO OF OF INSURANCE
COMMITTEE IS THAT -- HE DOES
MAKE THIS A PRIORITY OF LOOKING
AT IT.
INDEED THERE HAS BEEN A BIT
STATIC WITH REGARDS TO THE UP
TAKEN THE BALANCE OF COURSE IS
WANTING.
TO HOW THIS PROGRAM EXPAND IN A
SENSE OF OF OF TACKLING THE
UNINSURED MOTORIST POPULATION
OUT THERE.
BALANCED WITH WANTING TO
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE THEM TO BEING
IN THE ADMITTED MARKET SO
ACTUALLY NOT HAVE THIS BE LIKE
THE INSURER OF A FIRST RESORT IF
YOU WILL FOR CALIFORNIA LOW COST
AUTO POLICIES.
BUT FROM AN OVERALL STRATEGIC.
SPONSORING THIS MEASURE WITH
SUCH A RUBIO IS THAT IT'S HOW
CAN WE LOOK AT AT AGAIN WOULD
LEAN AWAY THE UNINSURED
POPULATION EXPAND THIS PROGRAM
AND THAT'S WHAT AND HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
WITH INDUSTRY AND WITH CONSUMER
A STAKEHOLDERS WHICH BEGAN --
LATE LAST YEAR AND EARLY AND ALL
THIS YEAR.
HENCE THE THREE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN TO
THE BILL TO CAPTURE SOME
PROPOSALS FROM THIS DISCUSSION
OF FOR EXAMPLE ALLOWING STUDENTS
TO BE ELIGIBLE. FOR THE PROGRAM
AT THE RESIDE AT THE SAME
ADDRESS PERMITTING.
COLOR FINING APPLICANTS PROOF OF
INCOME DOCUMENTATION BEING
SUBMITTED TO PRODUCER -- AMONG
OTHER AREAS THESE ARE AREAS IN
WHICH PART OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH INDUSTRY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS OF HOW.
TO FURTHER REFINE THE PROGRAM TO
GET AND HAVE IT BE HAVE THERE BE
A A THOUGHTFUL.
UPTICK IN THE POLICIES IN THIS
PROGRAM.
WELL THANK YOU THAT SIR I THINK
THAT'S REALLY GOOD NEWS SAID.
IT'S A PRODUCT THAT SHOULD BE
MORE POPULAR SO THAT'S GREAT
YEAR.
YEAH THE SENATOR LARA.
NOW INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
LARA'S TAKING A LOT LONGER AND
HARDER LOOK AT HIM THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO AND CANNED I'M
CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE IF IT
HASN'T BEEN MOVED I CAN MOVE IT.
WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU THANK
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES AYE BATES
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
HI BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX TO ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER.
YOU HAVE NOT WAY PRESENTATION ON
THIS BEFORE.
FIVE TWO IS IT YOUR INTENT TO
PRESENT THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
YES.
PLEASE BE BRIEF IT'S A SUSPENSE
[inaudible]
ITEM.
RIGHT.
AND THEN AFTER YOU PRESENT YOUR
IS WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE IN
ALL THE ROLL CALL BILLS BECAUSE
IT WILL GET.
DONE SO PLEASE BE BRIEF ON US
BEFORE FIVE TWO IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS -- SP
FOUR FIFTY TWO ON THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT -- IS
VERY PERSONAL TO ME TWENTY YEARS
AGO I HEARD THE THREE WORDS AND
NOBODY EVER WANTS TO HEAR.
YOU HAVE CANCER.
YEARS LATER WHEN I WAS SERVING
AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONSTITUENT CAME FOR WITH A
STORY ABOUT BEING CONTRACT
CONTACTED.
BY A RESEARCHER BEFORE SHE'D
EVEN DECIDED TO TELL HER FAMILY
ABOUT HER DIAGNOSIS OF CANCER.
SHE WAS FURIOUS SHE HAD NO IDEA
HOW THE RESEARCHER GOT HER
INFORMATION BECAUSE SHEWAS
UNAWARE THAT THE CANCER REGISTRY
EVEN EXISTED.
ALONG THAT HELD HER PERSONAL AND
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
I WAS SURPRISED TOO BECAUSE AS A
CANCER SURVIVOR MYSELF I WAS
ALSO AWARE OF THE REGISTRIES
EXISTENCE.
AS I DUG FURTHER INTO THE ISSUE
I REALIZE IS ACTUALLY A
STATEWIDE ISSUE.
THAT I BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO ADDRESS.
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THIS BILL
ALLOWS FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT IN AN ATTEMPT TO
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT. TO PICK
THE MOST EFFECTIVE METHOD OF
GETTING THE INFORMATIONAL
BROCHURES. TO THE INDIVIDUALS
ADDED TO THE REGISTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY I DO NOT AGREE
WITH THE COSTS ESTIMATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE LARGE VARIANCE IN COST FROM
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THE BILL
IS AMBIGUOUS IS UNREALISTIC IN
FACT THIS SOME BIG AMBIGUITY
SHOULD HELP LOWER THE COST
BECAUSE UNDER THE CURRENT BILL.
THE TO THE DEPARTMENT CAN EVEN
CHOOSE TO UTILIZE EMAIL RATHER
THAN STANDARD MAIL.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
CLAIMS THAT THEY WILL NEED TO
ADD EXTRA DATA FIELDS TO THEIR
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO SEND THESE
BROCHURES OUT.
HOWEVER THE REGISTRY ALREADY
COLLECTS ADDRESSES BECAUSE THEY-PROVIDE THEM TO THE RESEARCHERS
TO CONTACT THE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE REGISTRY.
FINALLY AT THE REGISTRY FILLS
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO
ADDITIONAL STAFFERS JUST TO
HANDLE THE CALL BY VOLUME FROM
THE NOTIFICATIONS.
WELL I THINK THAT SPEAKS TO THE
NEED OF THE BILL.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE FINDING OUT
ABOUT THE AGE CANCER SURVIVOR
SHOULD NOT BE FINDING OUT ABOUT
THE REGISTRIES EXISTENCE WHEN
YOU'RE BEING ASKED TO
PARTICIPATE IN A RESEARCH STUDY.
YOU SHOULD KNOW ABOUT IT WHEN
YOUR INFORMATION IS ENTERED.
MAYBE IF PATIENTS ARE NOTIFIED
EARLIER IN THE PROCESS THEY
WON'T BE AS SHOCKED TO FIND OUT
ABOUT THE REGISTRY.
I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL I LOOK FORWARD TO THE TO
THE CHANGE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
AND AT THE TIME APPROPRIATE I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER JONES ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
AND ONE PERSON COMING UP
[inaudible]
THIS YEAR.
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE STILL
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS.
THIS IS A DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP ISSUE WE THINK THAT
IT'S BEST.
THE PATIENT LEARN ABOUT THE
REGISTRY THROUGH THE TO THE
DOCTOR AS IT'S CURRENTLY
SUPPOSED TO BE.
AND WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE METHOD PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
THE REGISTRY IS ON A SIGNIFICANT
DELAY AND BY THE TIME THAT THE
MAIN REGISTRY GETS THE PAMPHLET
ARE THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PATIENTS.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE
RESEARCHERS WILL ALREADY REACHED
OUT BEFORE THEY GET THE
PAMPHLETS OUT TO THE PATIENTS.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THEIR NEEDS
TO BE A FIX TO THE REGISTRY.
AND AND THAT THERE'S A DIFFERENT
WAY TO ADDRESS THIS TO STILL GET
TO HAVE GUESTS REAL CONCERNS --
WE DO WE THINK THAT THIS WILL BE
A VERY COSTLY WAY TO HAVE THIS
ADDRESS AGAIN IF IT'S A DRESS
THE WAY THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
WITH THE DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP.
THEN THERE'S NO COST TO THE
STATE IT'S ALREADY.
BUT THE PAMPHLETS WILL BE A VERY
COSTLY WAY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE.
WHICH JONES WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO COME IN AND CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS A
MATTER OF FACT -- THE DOCTOR
PATIENT RELATIONSHIP IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON WHY --
LOTS OF CANCER PATIENTS ARE
RECEIVING THE INFORMATION OR
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED INFORMATION BECAUSE
IT'S COMING AT A TIME WHEN
THEY'RE BEING BOMBARDED WITH
LOTS OF OTHER INFORMATION.
OR THE DOCTORS ARE.
HE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH CANCER YOU HAVE SEVERAL
DOCTORS THAT ARE PROVIDING YOUR
CARE AND EACH DOCTOR MAY NOT
KNOW.
MAYBE EXPECTING THE OTHER
DOCTORS TO DO IT WHICH I THINK
WAS THE CASE IN MY CASE --
REGARDING THE THE FISCAL.
TIME.
CHALLENGES AGAIN I THINK ADDRESS
AT MY OPENING I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE A LETTER FROM THE
ASSOCIATION WILL TAKE THEIR
CONCERNS -- FROM THE TESTIMONY
TODAY AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE REGISTRY IN THE DEPARTMENT
ON THE BILL AND AGAIN LOOK FOR
TO YOUR SUPPORT WHEN AND WHEN
THE TIME COMES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOUR FIVE TWO WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING -- WE'RE GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL.
ON YOU WHAT YOU WANTED NIELSEN
FIRST.
SB.
THREE EIGHTY TWO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
JONES [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
JONES I'VE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX TO ZERO THEN
WILL GO TO MISTER HILL.
SB SIX NINE NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
JONES.
JONES I THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO
THEM WITHIN A MISTER DODD AS
THREE TO FOUR OO.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR JONES.
JONES I THE BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO SHOULD SB FIVE THIRTY
FOUR MISTER BRADFORD NEXT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR BATES.
JONES.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FOUR ZERO AND RUBIO GRAFFITI
HERE FOR THE THE RESEARCH TO
RUBIO DONE AND THEN HIS.
ALL RIGHT SO THOSE ARE ALL OF
THE DO THE ONE BY MISS ATKINS.
ON ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH ACT -- SEEING NO
QUESTIONS.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WANTS
TO SUPPORT SB
ONE TIONS SP.
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FORTY THREE
MISTER ALLEN ON CARBON TAXES IS
THERE SUPPORT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BRETT
I CAN BE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL PARTY AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IS OUR OPPOSITION SP.
FORTY THREE THEIR FILE THE FILE
NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FORTY THREE
WILL GO THE SUSPENSE.
BEST BE -- FIFTY FOUR MISTER
ALLEN ON PLASTIC POLLUTION -- IS
THERE SUPPORT.
I AM SURE TESTAMENT.
GOOD MORNING.
HE DOESN'T ALONE FOR THE LOCAL
NUMBER I WOKE US UP.
IT'S TWO FIFTY FOUR ALSO FOR THE
CLEANS HE'S LOBBY COALITION AND
HEAL THE BAND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY FOUR SIR OPPOSITION OF SP
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE LINE UP.
REMEMBER SINCE JUST A COMBAT THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL -- WE
APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS
RECOGNIZING SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS. TO CAL
RECYCLE WE EVEN THINK THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE MAYBE
EVEN GREATER THAN.
WHAT WAS IDENTIFIED I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO HOLD
THE BILL TO HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN NOW AND
THE END OF NEXT YEAR FOR A MORE
THOROUGH DISCUSSION THANK YOU?
DENNIS ALBION AND WE HAVE THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS AGAIN AND
COMPLIMENT THE STAFF IN
ANALYZING THIS VERY DIFFICULT
BILL BECAUSE OF THE AMBIGUITIES
AND BROADNESS OF IT.
SAYS TWENTY FOUR P. WISE THE
JUST FOR REFERENCE THE BOTTLE
BILL HAS OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY A PIECEWISE THAT THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO THAT VERY DISCREET
AND DEFINED.
BILL SO WE THINK THIS WILL BE
MUCH HIGHER THAN THAT -- AND
THEN THE THREE MILLION IN IN --
CONTRACTING BEGIN THIS BILL GOES
ON FOREVER AND SO HOW THIS THESE
COSTS WILL GO ON FOR FOR
GENERATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE FINANCE
THE FILE NO FINAL SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
FIFTY FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
THAT'S B. FIFTY NINE ON ON
THOMAS VEHICLES BY MR ALLEN IS
YOUR SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION MR FILE THE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP FIFTY NINE I SEE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS B..
FIFTY NINE WE GOT A SUSPENSE SP
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION SIR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILE THE FILE NO FILE
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP -- ONE THIRTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE S. C. TOO ON
ELECTION RECALLS BY MISTER ALLEN
MISTER SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
THE FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A CA
TO WILL GO.
TO I SEE A TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
S. B. WERE MOVE ON TO MISTER
BELL SP ELEVEN HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE IS THERE SUPPORT FOR S.
B. [inaudible]
ELEVEN SIR OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILE NO SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS B..
ELEVEN WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP
ONE FIFTY TWO BY MISTER BELL ON
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION IS THEIR
SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE THE
FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
ONE FIFTY TWO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP ONE NINETY SIX BY
MISTER BELL ON PROPERTY TAXES.
IS THERE SUPPORT FOR SP.
ONE NINETY SIX MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ENTRANCE WE ON THE
PREVIOUS ITEM SP ONE FIFTY TWO
LA METRO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU -- NO COMMENTS ON SP.
ONE NINETY SIX SEEING NONE.
SIR FILE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP ONE NINETY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SP FIFTEEN FOURTEEN TINO ON
LOCAL STATE SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENTS.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE.
I SHOULD HAVE SOMEBODY MOVING TO
THE MICROPHONE COME ON UP.
SP FIFTEEN GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBER SURELY DIE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PRECISION
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE SEEING NONE IS THERE
FILE.
NO FINAL SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FIFTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP.
EIGHTY SIX POURTANT TINO SCHOOL
SAFETY -- SIR SUPPORT.
DOCTOR SONYA CON PEDIATRIC
CRISIS SOLUTIONS ARE BOARD
CERTIFIED PEDIATRICIAN TRAUMA
DOCTOR I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FILE FILE
NO FINAL WITHOUT QUESTIONS AS TO
BE EIGHTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSION QUESTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP ONE SEVENTY TWO
FOURTEEN ONE FIREARM SISTER
SUPPORT [inaudible]
IS THERE [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP. FOR MORE CENTERED
GERMAN MEMBERS RIGHT GRIP ON THE
UP THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION GUNNERS A CALIFORNIA
THE NRA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE.
SIR FILE NEW FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION OR QUESTIONS
SP.
ONE SEVEN TWO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP THREE TWENTY EIGHT
POURTANT TINO SCHOOL START TIME.
IS THERE SUPPORT [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
I KNOW THE CHAIR STARTED.
SHANNON THOMPSON ON BEHALF OF
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER AND ON AND
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF EMPOWER
FAMILY CALIFORNIA ANIMUS SPECIAL
NEEDS PARALEGAL IN SUPPORT OF
ALL MY CLIENTS KIDS ALSO.
THANK YOU.
IS OPPOSITION SP.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT GOOD MORNING
STEVE ALL COME AT THE ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION.
SURELY DOWN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN.
OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE THE
FILE NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
MR WHITE HOUSE YOU HAVE A
QUESTION ON THE TIP YOUR HAND.
NOW WITHOUT OBJECTION SP THREE
TWENTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SP -- THREE FORTY NINE PORTENT
TINO MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX THEIR
SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION IS THERE A
FILE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP THREE FORTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AS BE FIVE OH NINE FORTINO
HOUSING CRISIS LICENSE PLATE.
THEIR SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION.
NO FILE.
THAT OBJECTION SP FIVE OH NINE
GO TO SUSPENSE SP FIVE TWENTY
ONE FORTINO -- SECTION -- EIGHT
TAX CREDITS.
SUPPORT ON BEHALF THE CITY OF
GLENDALE THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
CREAM GREASE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND SUPPORT AND SEE I
WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND THE THE
CHAIR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO
INCENTIVIZING MORE RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS TO VOLUNTARILY
PARTICIPATE IN SECTION.
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN RUN
KINGSTON REPRESENTING THE
APARTMENT SITUATION CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CITIES EAST BAY RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION -- PURPOSES
YOU GEORGE COUNTY AS WELL IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KATE BELLAMY OFF THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING HERE ASSOCIATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
CHECK OUT.
ARE YOU COMING UP TO OPPOSE US
SUPPORT RUBBLE SEGMENTATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION SHARE FILE THE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
OR QUESTIONS SP.
FIVE TWENTY ONE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP.
FIVE THIRTY TWO POURTANT TINO
REDEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
THEIR SPORT -- DAVE JONES ABOUT
GLENDALE SPORT [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE NEW FILE.
WITHOUT QUESTION OBJECTION SP
FIVE THIRTY TWO WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE SP SIX HUNDRED FORTINO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE FERTILITY
PRESERVATION IS THEIR SUPPORT.
ON A MOUNTAIN SMITH WITH
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE'S THEIR
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A FILE THE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT QUESTION OR
OBJECTION SB SIX HUNDRED WILL GO.
TO SUSPENSE SP SIX TWENTY
FOURTEEN A CRIMINAL OF FENDER
RECORDS SP SIX TWENTY IS OUR
SUPPORT DAVID JONES ABOUT CITY
PASADENA SUPPORT.
IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP SIX
TWENTY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE JUST
ON A PERSONAL NOTE NOTICE ALL
TEN OF MY BILLS WENT TO SUSPENSE
NONE OF THEM WERE DO PASSES.
TRYING TO BE EQUAL.
DULY NOTED YEAH.
I'M TRYING TO SET A GOOD EXAMPLE.
ALL RIGHT S. B..
WE'LL SEE.
ALWAYS ONE IN EVERY CROWD.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
MISS SKINNER SP -- EIGHTEEN KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSED ACT AS THEIR
SUPPORT. THIRTY SEVEN YOU CON
I'M ALSO THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
HUMAN RELATIONS COMMISSION FOR
THE CITY OF FREMONT IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MANY OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE YOU
KNOW FILE SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
EIGHTEEN WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
CRISPY FORTY FOUR BY MUSCULAR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
SUPPORT YES MILAN ON BEHALF OF
CERES AND MANY OF ITS CORPORATE
MEMBERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SIR FILED A FILE NO FILE SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FORTY FOUR WE'LL GO TO SUSPEND
SAYS BE.
FORTY NINE BY MISS SKINNER ON
ENERGY EFFICIENCY [inaudible]
ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION SIR FILE THE FILE
NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FORTY NINE
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP -- THREE
TEN SCAN ON JURY SELECTION IS
THEIR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
THREE TEN WITH -- SUSPENSE SP
THREE THIRTY MISS SKINNER ON
HOUSING CRISIS ACTIVE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IS THERE
SUPPORT.
IS -- OPPOSITION.
INGER MILLER MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF A RED DEAD WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL.
DAVID JONES ABOUT CITIES OF SAN
MARCOS AND SO ON A BEACH IN
OPPOSITION.
I'LL POST ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
AND SUNNYVALE NEIGHBORS MY NAME
IS MAILING STEPHAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE ANY FILE
THE FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
THREE THREE ZERO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP.
THREE THIRTY SEVEN MISS CAMERON
CHILD SUPPORT IS THERE SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE FILE.
NO FINAL SEE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP THREE
THIRTY SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB -- TWENTY
FOUR BY MS LABOR ON STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE FILE.
THERE'S NO FILE AND NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP TWENTY FOUR
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP ONE
SEVEN FOUR BY MISS SLAVE ON
EARLY EDUCATION REIMBURSEMENTS.
THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE FILE NO FILE
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
ONE SEVEN FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP TWO FIFTY TWO I'M A
SLAVE ON TAXES EXCLUSION MOBILE
HOME PARKS.
IS THERE SUPPORT IS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
IS THEIR FILE FILE NO FILE
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
TWO FIVE TWO WE GOT A SUSPENSE
SP THREE TWELVE I MISS SLAVE ON
VETERANS SERVICE DOG ASSISTANCE
IS THEIR SUPPORT -- YES PREP
BIKE -- SPEAKING AS SOMEONE WHO
OWNS A SERVICE I CAN SAY THAT
IT'S MADE ME A GREAT DEAL OF
MONEY ON PRESCRIPTIONS AND
THERAPY.
AND I THINK THE SAME WOULD BE
TRUE FOR THE VETERAN COMMUNITY
AT LARGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT -- QUESTIONS ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP THREE TWELVE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
SP -- FIVE SIXTY FOUR MISLAID ON
DIGITAL DEPICTION OF INDIVIDUALS
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION SIR FILE TO
FILE AND NO FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FIVE SIXTY FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP FIVE SEVENTY FOUR BY
MISS LABOR ON FRAGRANCE
CHEMICALS RIGHT TO KNOW ACT.
IS THERE SUPPORT [inaudible]
PROPOSITION.
THEIR FILE THE FILE THERE IS NO
FILE SING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
FIVE SEVEN FOUR WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE THAT IS OUR FIRST PAGE.
WE WILL GO TO OUR SECOND PAGE ON
MR WINNERS ESPY -- FOURTEEN ON
CONSERVATORSHIP.
IS THERE SUPPORT PRESS BE.
FORTY IS OUR OPPOSITION SP.
FORTY I SEE LOTS OF MOVEMENT BUT
NOBODY GOING FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO COMMENTS ON
SB.
FORTY FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE A
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
AS BE FORTY WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
SP.
FORTY EIGHT TIMES TO WINTER ON
LOW BARRIER NAVIGATION CENTERS
THEIR SUPPORT.
THE NIKON VICE CHAIR THE HUMAN
RELATIONS COMMISSION FOR THE
CITY FREMONT IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
SIR OPPOSITION TEST BE.
FORTY EIGHT ARE YOU SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
YES ON BEHALF OF EMPOWER FAMILY
CALIFORNIA AND EDUCATE ADVOCATE
WE SUPPORT.
ART IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION SP.
FORTY EIGHT FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
IS THREE FORTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE S. B. FIFTY BY MISTER
WINNER ON PLANNING ZONE AND
HOUSING.
IS OUR SUPPORT FOR SB.
FIFTY IS THERE OPPOSITION SP.
FIFTY PLEASE LINE UP.
PATRICIA BB WITH LAST
CALIFORNIAN DOT COM IN THE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIFTY THANK YOU.
INGER MILLER MAYOR OF THE CITY
EVER READ THAT AND WE ASK THAT
YOU VOTE NO ON SB FIFTY FOR THE
REASON THAT IT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY WHICH IS THAT.
OF IT WE WE ASK THAT THE
DEFINITION OF JOBS RICH
COMMUNITY BE DEFINED IN THE BILL
AND NOT.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE STATE AS AS ASKED
FOR BY THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND ALSO BY.
THE ASSOCIATES AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF PLANNERS.
MR MEMBERS ENTRY INTO HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL THEY VOTED TO ADOPT
THE LOOK OF A POSITION OF THE
POLES ABOVE THE CITY LOS ANGELES.
AND ALSO THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND OPPOSITION.
MAILINGSTUFF.
OPPOSING STRONGLY ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY SUNNYVALE
NEIGHBORS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID
JONES ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
GLENDALE PASADENA SOLANA BEACH
AND THE CITY'S MARIN IN
OPPOSITION.
A ROBBER COUPLE SECOND A TENS
UNIT STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE HERE TO
SPEAK ON S. B.. FIFTY ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE NO FILE
SEEING NO QUESTIONS.
SB -- FIFTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP SIXTY NINE
WEST WING ON OCEAN RESILIENCY.
IS THERE SUPPORT IN FAVOR OF SB.
SIXTY NINE HI CAITLYN CLUE OVER
THE CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER
ALLIANCE A QUICK NO IS A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL WE HAVE
TAKEN MOMENTS.
BUT TO THIS POINT TO REDUCE THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS BILL BY
REMOVING NONESSENTIAL PROGRAMS
WERE CONTINUING TO OFFER
AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE FISCAL
IMPACT AND WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING.
BUT WITH YOU AND HOPEFULLY THE
SIMPLY THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR JUST MOVE ON TO THE
PACIFIC -- SHELLFISH GROWS I
JUST WANTED TO DO A LITTLE BIT.
ON THE FISCAL SINGS SO THIS
APPROPRIATIONS IT SEEMS TO HAVE
A HIGH PRICE TAG BUT IF ONE
CONSIDERS.
THE INCREDIBLE VALUE OF OCEAN
AND COAST TO CALIFORNIA AND ALL
THE PACIFIC RIM COUNTRIES THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY OF SHARING
MUCH OF THIS COST WITH THE
JOINING PACIFIC RIM COUNTRIES
LIKE JAPAN.
AND THE OTHER INSTITUTIONS THAT
WE HAVE HERE SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
BEAR THE COST WILL BUT JUST BEAR
IN MIND THIS IS AN AND VERY VERY
IMPORTANT -- COMMITMENT AND
INVESTMENT IN OUR COASTAL --
COASTAL DEPENDENT INDUSTRIES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THEIR OPPOSITION SP.
SIXTY NINE YES MISTER MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORCES
SOCIALIZATION AND THE FORCE
LANDLORDS OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE FOUR KEY
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL.
AS KNOWN COMMITTEE STAFF
ANALYSIS COST PRESSURES IN THE
FOUR FOUR MILLION DOLLAR RANGE
WITH TWENTY FIVE P. WISE WE
DON'T THINK THE A FORTY
PROVISIONS ARE NEED IN THE BILL
WE'VE ACTUALLY OUGHT TO RESPECT
ME REMOVE THEM.
WE THINK EXISTING ALREADY COVERS
A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- CARLSON SOCIALLY
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS -- FOR VERY
MUCH THE SAME REASONS
ARTICULATED BY THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS.
WE DO THINK BEFORE SHE PROVISION
SO WE NEED TO BE LOOKED AT
PROBLEMATIC FOR THE ENTIRE BILL
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE SEEING NONE IS THERE
A FIRE NO FIRE NO FINAL SING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIXTY NINE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SP.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN MISTER WEINER
ON TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IS
THEIR SUPPORT.
PLEASE LINE UP.
LINDA COMMISSION ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
ESTHER BEAR ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WALKS IN SUPPORT.
TOP OF THE MATS ON BEHALF OF THE
SAFE ROUTES PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT.
ENGINE THREE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION BOTH
IN SUPPORT.
STEVE WELCOME KATHY ON MEDICAID
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION SPORT.
TWENTY OPPOSITION SP.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN IS THERE A FILE
THE FILE NO FILE SEE NO
QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP ONE TWENTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP ONE
FORTY TWO MISTER WEINER.
EMPLOYEES LACTATION
ACCOMMODATION IS THERE SUPPORT
FOR SP. ONE FORTY TWO THIRTY ONE
REPRESENTS AMERICAN CANYON
PEDIATRICS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I SEE ANOTHER PERSON RUNNING
OVER.
TAKE YOUR TIME IT'S ALL GOOD.
JUNIOR CASSIDY CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB.
ONE FORTY TWO SEEING NONE THE
FILE NO FILE -- SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
ONE FORTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SP ONE FIFTY NINE BY MISTER
WEINER ON HIV -- ON HIV IS THERE
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE MEASURE MAY
HAVE THE CITY OR STATE HOLLYWOOD
AND SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS HER FILE THE FILE
NO FILE AN SP.
ONE FIFTY NINE WITHOUT OBJECTION
I SEE NO QUESTIONS ABOUT
OBJECTION SP ONE FIFTY NINE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
SP TWO EIGHTY EIGHT BY MR WYNN
ON ELECTRICITY ENERGY STORAGE.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRD AT DEL
CARE EXECUTOR TO THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION ON
BEHALF OF OUR FIVE HUNDRED
BUSINESS MEMBERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE URGE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PETER COREY WITH THE SOLAR
RIGHTS ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF TWO EIGHTY EIGHT AND
I AM A CONSTITUENT OF YOURS.
FROM CLAREMONT CALIFORNIA.
THE BEST STATE SENATE DISTRICT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MR MEMBERS JOHN DORY ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR SOLAR CHOICE
AND SON RUN INSTRUCTS FORT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO MANY HUNTER
ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PHILLY
PARTLY FROM THE BEAUTIFUL CITY
OF LOCKING OUT OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF TWO EIGHT
EIGHT YOU FORGOT TO SAY LIVE SIX
HOUSES AWAY FROM ME.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CHURCH
DOESN'T PASS ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLAR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FILE FILE
NO FILE -- SEE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR GO TO SUSPENSE -- WE
WILL MOVE ON TO MISS JACKSON'S
BILLS -- SP FORTY SIX ON
EMERGENCY SERVICES IS THERE
SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP.
FORTY SIX WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
S. B. TWO TWO EIGHT MS JACKSON
MASTER PLAN ON AGING BECAUSE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SP
[inaudible]
TWO TWO EIGHT SIR OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILE THE FILE NO FILE --
WITHOUT SEEING ANY QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
TWO TWO EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE AS BEFORE TWENTY FOUR
MS JACKSON ON TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
IS THERE SUPPORT PRESS BEFORE.
TWENTY FOUR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JUST WENT ON FOR THE CLEAN SEES
LOBBYING COALITION -- ON THE
FISCAL IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
THAT WE GET A HANDLE ON THE
WASTE AND THE LETTER BECAUSE BY
THESE ITEMS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PAY.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR AND THIS AND THIS IS
GOING TO A VOTE THAT ON HIS SO
SHE WASTE OF MONEY THANK YOU.
TONY KHAN FULL OF THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON NICOTINE IN TOBACCO
AND ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
PRODUCTS FOR FIVE YEARS NOW.
SINCE A TODDLER ACTUALLY DIED IN
NEW YORK STATE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL A GIVEN THE
FACT THAT WE'RE WE'VE BEEN KIND
OF LEFT LISTING IN THE WIN BY
THE FDA.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON A ROBIN IS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION.
JUST BEFORE.
TWENTY FOUR SEEING NONE IS THERE
A FIRE NO FIRE NO FINAL SCENE NO
QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FOUR TWENTY
FOUR WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT MS JACKSON ON
CALIFORNIA TAX EXPENDITURE
REVIEW BOARD IS THEIR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DANIELLE CANDOR
BECAUSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SURELY DOWN BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOL VERSUS
YUSHIN SUPPORT.
TAKE YOUR TIME IT'S OKAY.
BUT ASK OF ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AND SUPPORT.
ART IS THERE OPPOSITION DESK
BEFORE. SIXTY EIGHT TO RESTORE
MAY REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION A LARGE
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS AS WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER.
WERE TAKEN IMPOSING LESS AMENDED
WE HOPE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THOSE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
IS THEIR FILE THE FILE NO FILE --
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP FOUR SIXTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AS BEFORE NINETY THREE
BY MISS JACKSON.
ON EDUCATION SEX EQUITY IS THERE
SUPPORT FOR SP.
FOUR NINETY THREE IS THERE
OPPOSITION COME ON OUT.
GOOD MORNING CYNTHIA GARRETT OF
A CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY AND CO
PRESIDENT OF FAMILIES ADVOCATING
FOR CAMPUS QUALITY -- S. BEFORE
NINETY THREE DIRECTLY
CONTRADICTS APPELLATE COURT
RULINGS IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR COURTS HAVE ALREADY FORKED
OUT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR SCHOOLS TO PAY FOR
VIOLATING THOSE RULES -- I DON'T
THINK THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO PASS A BILL
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO COST
SCHOOLS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN DEFENDING LAWSUITS.
REIMBURSING ATTORNEYS FEES AND
PAYING DAMAGES.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH CISNEROS I AM THE
FIRST GENERATION HERE FROM A
FAMILY OF IMMIGRANTS AND WE HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD TO PROVIDE
COLLEGE EDUCATION FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
MY SON WAS NOTIFIED TWO WEEKS
BEFORE GRADUATION THAT THERE WAS
AN ACCUSATION OF AN UNWANTED
KISSED BY A GIRL HE HAD DATED IN
THE PAST.
THIS IS A FALSE ACCUSATION WHICH
IS CUSTOM EXTREME EMOTIONAL
DEVASTATION HE HAS LOST OUT ON
JOB INTERVIEWS WE WERE UNABLE TO
ATTEND HIS GRADUATION CEREMONY
HE IS NOW IN THERAPY AND HE MAY
NEVER BE ABLE TO WORK IN HIS
FIELD OF MECHANICAL ENGINEERING.
WE HAVE SPENT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN LEGAL FEES BECAUSE
HIS ENTIRE FUTURE IS AT STAKE WE
WILL BE FORCED TO FILE A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE UNIVERSITY IF HIS
RECORD IS NOT CLEAR.
THIS IS DEVASTATING MANY
MINORITY FAMILIES MANY THAT
CANNOT COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
AS THEIR FILE THE FILE.
IS NO FILES SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FOUR NINETY THREE WILL GO ON
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO MISTER
HERTZBERG'S BILLS SB FIFTY ONE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS CANNABIS
IS THEIR SUPPORT FOR S. P..
FIFTY ONE IS OUR OPPOSITION FOR
S. B. FIFTY ONE IS THERE A FINAL
FIVE THERE'S NO FILE THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FIFTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP.
SIXTY THREE MR HERTZBERG STUDENT
LOAN DEBT FORGIVENESS IS THERE
SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION SIR FILE THE
FILE NO FILE LOCAL [inaudible]
NO QUESTIONS.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS B. SIXTY THREE
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP.
TWO FIFTY FOUR MR HERTZBERG ON
THE CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY -- IS THEIR SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION ARE YOU COMING
DOWN THE SUPPORT NO [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
TWO FIFTY FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP THREE EIGHTEEN
RESEARCH FOR CONSUMER PROTECTION
BAIL BONDS -- IS THERE SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DAN GORDER MELVIN
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA --
PROD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DANIEL CANDOR
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION OVER IT DOESN'T --
ORGANIZATIONS IN THAT COALITION
IN AND WE ARE ALSO PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
CLOSER FILE THE FILE NO FINAL
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP THREE EIGHTEEN WILL
GODDESSES SPENCE SP.
THREE THREE TWO MR HERTZBERG ON
WASTEWATER TREATMENT IS THERE
SUPPORT.
IT WHEN CLEWER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HIS THEIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
THREE THREE TWO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP THREE FORTY TWO MR
HERTZBERG ON ADVERTISING.
TICKET WEBSITES IS THERE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
LOSER OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE FILE YOU KNOW FILE
NO QUESTIONS SP.
THREE FORTY TWO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE -- MOVING ON TO MISTER
NEAL SENT ON A WE HAVE ONE MORE
I'M SORRY SP FIVE TWENTY MISTER
HERZBERG ELECTRICAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FIVE TWENTY HOST A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON MISTER NIELSON.
CLASS B. SEVENTY ON ELECTRICITY
THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION THEIR FILE THE
FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP SEVENTY
GOES TO SUSPENSE.
AS B. TWO TWO SIX BY MISTER
NIELSON ON WATERSHED RESTORATION.
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION IF I
KNOW FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP TWO TO SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO
MISTER STEARNS -- BILLS SP ONE
TWENTY FIREARMS [inaudible]
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO SUPPORT NO OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILES A FILE NO FILE THAT
OBJECTION SP ONE TWENTY FOUR GO
TO SUSPENSE SP. SIXTY TWO ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOREST
RESTORATION IS THEIR SUPPORT.
REST BEFORE.
SIXTY TWO IS THERE OPPOSITION
FRESH BEFORE.
SIXTY TWO LOTS OF MOVEMENT I
CAN'T TELL.
DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE SO.
IS -- FILE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BEFORE
SIXTY TWO WITH A SUSPENSE SP.
FOUR SIXTY THREE ON NATURAL
GRASS STORAGE.
IS THERE SUPPORT [inaudible]
MR OPPOSITIONS.
NO FILE AND THERE'S NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BEFORE
SIXTY THREE WERE SUSPENSE SP.
SIX THIRTEEN STATE AGENCY
GREENHOUSE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION IS THERE SUPPORT FOR
SB SIX THIRTEEN IS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE TEAM WILL GO OUT
OF SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
SIX TWENTY SIX STERN ON
FRANCHISE TAX EXEMPTIONS FOR
ARMED FORCES IS THERE SUPPORT
PRESS B..
SIX TWENTY SIX IS THERE
OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SIX TWENTY SIX WE'RE GONNA
SUSPENSE.
SIX THIRTY THREE SANTA SUSANA
FIELD LABORATORY.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX THIRTY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB.
SIX THIRTY SIX STERN ELECTIONS
BALLOT LABELS.
IS THERE SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
IS THERE A FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SIX THREE SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE SP.
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR AVERAGE
CONTAINER CYCLING ACT IS THERE
SUPPORT.
DROP IS ISSHIN IS THERE A FILE
FILE.
YOU KNOW FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS B. SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR WITH A SUSPENSE SP.
SEVEN THIRTY STERN COMMISSION ON
THE FUTURE OF WORK.
S. B. SEVEN THIRTY AS THEIR
SUPPORT. FOR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
THERE IS NO FILE AS B. SEVEN
THIRTY WILL DAUGHTER SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BE.
SEVEN FIFTY TWO CALUMET
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN ON TECH
EQUITY.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS TO BE SEVEN
FIFTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP.
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR ON ELECTRICITY
MICROGRAMS THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE
FILE NO FILE OTHER QUESTIONS
NINE WITHOUT OBJECTION AS THREE
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO DOCTOR PAN.
SP ONE SEVEN FIVE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE IS THERE SUPPORT FOR SP.
ONE SEVEN FIVE OUR MOUNTAIN
SMITH WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
AND SUPPORT.
I SEE MORE ACTIVITY.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
VIDEO BORN AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION OR IS THAT MORE
SUPPORT COME ON OVER.
TRAPEZOID IN.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FILE THE
FILE.
THERE'S NO FILE SEE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP ONE SEVEN
FIVE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE AS
BEES -- THREE SIX THREE DOCTOR
PAN WORK FORCE WORKPLACE SAFETY.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
FOR THREE SIXTY THREE MR
OPPOSITION.
FOR THREE SIXTY THREE IS -- FILE
A FILE NO QUESTIONS SP THREE
SIXTY THREE WITH A SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AS BEFORE TWENTY ONE DOCTOR PAN
CHILDREN'S CABINET OF CALIFORNIA.
IS THERE SUPPORT IS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING A COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS LISA JENKINS WITH
PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA -- I
UNDERSTAND IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
HARD TO ASSESS THE FULL FISCAL
IMPACT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT REALLY GONNA KNOW THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
UNTIL AFTER THE CABINET HAS MET
PROBABLY A NUMBER OF TIMES -- SO
I ASK YOU GUYS TO PLEASE
CONTINUE TO SAFEGUARD THE FISCAL
RESOURCES OF THE STATE AND BEAR
THAT IN MIND TYPOS THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY FILE THE FILE NO FILE.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION AND
QUESTIONS US BEFORE TWENTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP.
FIVE OH THREE DOCTOR PANA MEDIC
COW MANAGED CARE PLANS IS THERE
SUPPORT.
WAS OUR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE NO
FINAL.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP FIVE OH THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP FIVE TWELVE DR FAN
LONG TERM SERVICES IS THERE
SUPPORT.
AS OUR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE A FILE NO FILE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP.
FIVE TWELVE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
FIVE FIFTY SIX DOCTRINE
PROFESSIONAL LAND SURVEYORS AND
ENGINEERS AS THEIR SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION.
IS -- FILE FILE NO FILE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SP FIVE FIVE SIX GO TO SUSPENSE.
TWO PAGES DOWN.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
MISTER HILL.
SP ONE NINETY NINE ON THE PUBLIC
YOU TO LEASE COMMISSION OFFICE
OF SAFETY ADVOCATES IS THEIR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE FILE NO FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ONE NINETY NINE SP ONE NINETY
NINE GO TO SUSPENSE SP THREE OH
FOUR BY MR HELL CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE ELDER ABUSE.
IS THERE SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION
AS THEIR FILE FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AND QUESTIONS
SP THREE OR FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AS BEFORE -- TWENTY
FIVE ON HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONERS
CONDUCT.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
PLEASE DROP POSITION.
SHARE FILES A FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FOUR TWENTY FIVE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE -- SP FIVE FORTY NINE
P. YOU SEE RATES CAPITAL
STRUCTURE CHANGES IS THERE
SUPPORT.
MISSOURI POSITION IS THEIR FILE.
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FIVE FORTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SCA -- THREE
PROPERTY TAXATION INHERITANCE
EXCLUSION.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SING NO
QUESTIONS ON OBJECTION SCA.
THREE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
I SEE A FIVE TAXATION SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PARTIAL TAX.
IS THERE ANY SUPPORT.
PRESS C. A..
FIVE GOOD MORNING SURELY DOWN
HALF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE FILE YOU KNOW FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AND QUESTIONS
AND SEE A FIVE FULL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO MISTER MINING ESPY
TWO HUNDRED A SAFE AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND -- SEARCH
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR FOR TWO GROUPS THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH FOLKS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY THE REGULATORS --
WITHOUT THIS FUNDING WE CANNOT
GET THIS JOB DONE -- THESE SMALL
SYSTEMS SIMPLY CANNOT SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES THEY NEED THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION AND
THE CAPITAL FUNDS THAT COME OUT
OF BOND MEASURES DON'T COVER
THAT -- FOR SERIES AND ALL THE
BUSINESSES THAT IT REPRESENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE PULLED
THAT WE STILL HAVE BETWEEN HOFFA
MILLION AND A MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DON'T HAVE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
IT'S HIGH TIDE IT'S HIGH TIME
FOR THIS TO BE DONE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
TWO HUNDRED WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AS BEFORE -- SEVEN MISTER MONEY
ON MEDICARE SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT
COVERAGE ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION SIR FILE THE FILE
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE -- SEVEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MISTER DODD TO FOURTEEN MEDIC
COW CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONS.
IS THERE SUPPORT. ZERO POSITION
SIR FILE FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP TWO FOURTEEN WE'RE
GONNA SUSPENSE AS BE TWO FORTY
SEVEN WILDLAND FIRE PRESENT
PREVENTION.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION.
MR FILE THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP TWO FORTY SEVEN
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE AS BE TWO
FIFTY THREE BY MISTER DOT
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SIR FILES.
NO FILE OTHER QUESTIONS NON
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP TWO FIFTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AS B.
TWO SIXTY THREE BY MISTER DOT ON
TAXATION.
SEARCH SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION SIR FILE FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP TWO
SIXTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO MISTER BRADFORD SP
TWO EIGHTEEN EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION -- SIR SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION SIR FILE FILE NO
FINAL SCENE NO QUESTIONS SP TWO
EIGHTEEN WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SP SIX FIVE EIGHT MISTER
BRADFORD ON CANNABIS -- SIR
SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE THE
FILE.
YOU KNOW FILE -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIX FIVE EIGHT WITH
OTHER SUSPENSE SP SEVEN OH FOUR
BY MISTER BRADFORD -- MORE YOU
UNIVERSAL TELEPHONE SERVICE ACT
SIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION SIR FILE FILE.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. SEVEN OH FOUR WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A MISS CAVELL
GYRO SP.
TWO THIRTY LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING CENTER SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS -- FILE A FILE
NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS AND
SPEED.
TO THIRTY WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FOUR FIFTY FOUR MS CAVIAR WATER
RIGHTS HEARING OFFICE FUND IS
THERE SUPPORT FOR SP.
FIVE FOUR FIVE FOUR IS OUR
OPPOSITION FOR US BEFORE.
FIVE FOUR SEEING NEITHER IS
THERE FILE FOR US BEFORE FIVE
FOUR NO FILE NO QUESTIONS AS
BEFORE FIFTY FOUR WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FIVE THIRTY NINE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IS THERE SUPPORT.
HI THERESA COMSTOCK WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS ON THEIR BEHALF WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE DEARBORN AMERICAN KENNY
PEDIATRICS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE A FILE NO FILE
IN FIVE THIRTY NINE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FIVE THIRTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SP FIVE EIGHTY ONE CANNABIS
LICENSING -- IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FIVE EIGHTY
ONE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB SIX SIX NINE MS KELLY ARE
SAFE DRINKING WATER FUND IS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB.
SIX SIX NINE IS -- OPPOSITION
FOR SP SIX SIX NINE IS THEIR
FILE THE FILE.
NO FILE -- WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
SIX SIX NINE WITH -- SUSPENSE SP.
SIX NINETY SEVEN I MISS CARRIER --
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS SUPERVISION
IS THEE SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION IS THERE A
FILE THE FILE NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
SIX NINETY SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO MISTER
MOORE LOCK.
SP TWO FORTY ONE A CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION PROGRAM
IS THERE SUPPORT.
FOR TWO FORTY ONE IS THEIR
OPPOSITION FIRST BE TWO FORTY
ONE IS THERE A FILE FOR SP TWO
FOR AWHILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP TWO
FORTY ONE WE GOT A SUSPENSE SP.
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR ON UNDERGROUND
ELECTRICAL WIRES IS THERE
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE A FLAT NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
B. FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WHEELER
SUSPENSE.
MR GLAZIERS BILLS SP.
TWO FORTY EIGHT A RENTER'S
CREDIT.
SIR SUPPORT.
COME ON UP.
TAKE YOUR TIME IT'S ALL GOOD.
GOOD MORNING CAPE TOWN HALF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION ARE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING HOLLY MICHON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
ARE YOU STILL SUPPORT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TENNESSEE
GATHER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE FILE.
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS US BE TWO
FORTY EIGHT WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX SO
EIGHT BLAZER ARCHITECTS.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION IS THEIR
FILE THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIX AWAIT WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB SIX SO NINE GLAZER
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS IS
THEIR SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION SIR
FILE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP SIX OH NINE
WE GOT A SUSPENSE SP.
SIX SEVENTEEN ON PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS.
SB -- SIX SEVENTEEN THEIR
SUPPORT.
AS OUR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE NEW FILE.
THERE'S NO FILE -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIX SEVENTEEN WE'RE
GONNA SUSPENSE SP.
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT ON RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PILOT PROGRAM.
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SP SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT COME ON OUT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LAURA MAGNANI FOR
THE AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE -- WE WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT WILL
COST SOME MONEY BUT IT WILL SAVE
A LOT MORE MONEY SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OPPOSITION TO SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
SIR FILE.
FIVE SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON MS RUBIO ESPYS TWO
SEVENTY THREE ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS THEIR SUPPORT --
OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE FILE.
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
TWO SEVENTY THREE WE GOT A
SUSPENSE.
SP FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
DR COHN PEDIATRIC SOLUTIONS FOR
ALL OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS ALSO BASED HERE THE
HUMAN RELATIONS COMMISSION TO
THE CITY OF FREMONT WEAPON
WORKING VERY HARD TO GET A
TOBACCO RETAIL LICENSE GOING ON
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER I'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD ON THIS ISSUE.
AND IT'S A PART OF REALLY THAT
THE STATES AND CITIES OF THE
COUNTRY TAKE.
UP TAKE ACTION IN FACE OF AN FDA
WHICH IS BASICALLY FAILING TO
REGULATE ANY OF THESE PRODUCTS
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE IF
THEY HAVE THEIR WAY.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ANY OPPOSITION.
SIR FINAL THE FILE NO FILE
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
WILL GO THE SUSPENSE SP.
SIX FOURTEEN ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS OUR SUPPORT MR
OPTICIAN.
IS THERE A FILE FILE NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
SIX FOURTEEN WE GOT A SUSPENSE.
SB SIX FIFTY ON CANCER
MEDICATION IS THERE SUPPORT. TWO
MEMBERS OUT OF MOUNTAIN SMITH A
CO SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE NO FILE -- NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP SIX FIFTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP
SIX SIX EIGHT CONFIRA TURNS
THEIR SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE YOU
KNOW FILE.
KNOW QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP SIX SIX EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP.
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE ON VETERAN'S
RENTAL HOUSING IS THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR SB.
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE IS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE IS THEIR FILE IF I KNOW
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE IS GOING TO
SUSPENSE SP.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ON TAXES OF
MODULE WHAT MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE NO FILE -- FEE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AS V..
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WE GOT A
SUSPENSE SP THREE TWENTY NINE BY
MISS MITCHELL.
IS THERE SUPPORT IT'S
DISCRIMINATION HOUSING SUPPORT.
TENNIS TOGETHER STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION.
THE PORT SUPPORT FOR ALLIANCE-RETURN AMERICANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT ALL RIGHTS SUPPORTERS
KEEP COMMON.
WE MEASURE OUR BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD AND
SUPPORT.
WROTE A COUPLE SET MY TENURE
STRONG SUPPORT.
IS THERE MORE SUPPORT.
I MEAN RUBIO SEVEN CISCO HAS THE
REST MAY SUPPORT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS KATE BELLAMY OFF THE
CALIFORNIA REAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
AROUND KINGSTON REPRESENTING
THREE REGIONAL APARTMENT
ASSOCIATIONS PERSECUTION.
OF ORANGE COUNTY EAST BAY RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CITY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY FILE.
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL THAT WOULD KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ESTIMATES THE BILL
WILL RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
COMPLAINTS PER YEAR -- DRIVING
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF
GENERAL PHONE COSTS ARE
ESTIMATED AT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SEVEN
HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THREE OR EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP THREE
TWENTY NINE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
GO TO OUR LAST PAGE.
MR UMBERG SP -- THREE NINETEEN
SCHOOL SECURITY OFFICERS AS
THEIR SUPPORT.
CENTER FOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MANY OTHERS SINCE THEIR
OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILE.
NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP THREE
NINETY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SP FIVE SEVENTY SIX STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY IS THERE
SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FIVE SEVENTY SIX
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MR ARCHER LETTERS BILLS SP THREE
NINETY FIVE WILDLIFE.
COLLISION WITH A VEHICLE -- SP
THREE NINETY FIVE IS OUR SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
THE DOG COMING UP TO TESTIFY.
OKAY THE DOG JUST MOVING.
THE ROAD.
I WAS.
WE WANT TO ACCOMMODATE THAT
PUPPY.
THIS IS A PUPPY FRIENDLY PLACE
ALL RIGHT ANY -- FILE ON SP
THREE NINETY FIVE FIVE NO FILE --
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP THREE
NINETY FIVE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
AS BEFORE -- FIVE RECLAIMED
ASPHALT PAVEMENT.
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KATE ON
AROUND THE CITY COUNCIL LABORS
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION -- FILE THE
FILE.
NO FILED NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE -- FIVE
ABOUT A SUSPENSE AS P. SIX SIX
TWO ARCHULETA GREEN ELECTRIC X.
ELECTROLYTE HYDROGEN.
ELECTRO LYTIC HYDROGEN SKEWS ME --
IS THERE SUPPORT IS THERE.
OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE FILE.
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIX SIX TO FOUR GOT
A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A MISTER WAY
SO -- SP FOUR TWENTY TWO TAX
CREDITS -- THEIR SUPPORT SIR
OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE FILE NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE.
TWENTY TWO WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
SP FIVE TWENTY EIGHT ON THE I.
BANK -- THEIR SUPPORT.
SHOP IS IT SHOULDN'T SIR FILE
THE FILE.
YOU KNOW FILE -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP SIX
NINETEEN MR WAITS ON PROMISE
ZONES CREDIT REPORTING IS THERE
SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION THEIR FILE THE
FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
SIX NINETEEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SP FIVE THIRTY FIVE ON TAXATION
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AS THEIR
SUPPORT -- OPPOSITIONS THE FILE.
AND I'M SORRY LIKE SAY THAT
WRONG -- SIX THIRTY FIVE SKEWS
ME SP.
SIX THIRTY FIVE THE FILE EVEN
THOUGH IT CHANGED BY HUNDRED NO
FILE.
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIX THIRTY FIVE
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SB.
SIX SIXTY SEVEN GREENHOUSE GASES
RECYCLING FACILITIES IS THEIR
SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION THE FILE
NO FILE.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SIX SIX SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
AS BE SIX NINETY WATER QUALITY.
TIJUANA RIVER HAS THEIR SUPPORT.
IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILES.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP SIX NINETY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO MR STONE SP FOUR FOUR
SIX ON MEDIC COW.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THEIR OPPOSITION IS THERE A
FILE NO FILE.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP FOUR FOUR SIX WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
AS BEFORE SEVENTY SIX MR STONE
ON PHARMACY EMPLOYER ADVISORY
TASK FORCES THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE.
IS THEIR QUESTIONS ARE THERE
QUESTIONS NO QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION P.
FOUR SEVENTY SIX WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE'VE ALREADY MOVED SP
FOUR FIFTY TWO TO SUSPENSE WILL
MOVE ON TO MISTER JONES IS SP.
SIX SIX THREE OUR PROPERTY TAX
VETERANS IS THERE SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION THEIR FILE FILE
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIX SIX THREE WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO MISSOURI TADO SP FOUR
FIFTY THREE OLDER ADULTS IS
THEIR SUPPORT [inaudible]
PROPOSITION.
THEIR FILE FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP FOUR FIFTY THREE WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE.
AS BEFORE NINETY MR TOP COW
FRESH IS THEIR SUPPORT.
OVER A COUPLE OF STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE FILE NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
BEFORE NINETY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
SP.
FIVE OH ONE ON ARMORIES -- SIR
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE THEIR OPPOSITION IS
THERE A FILE FILE OKAY NO FILES.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP FIVE OH ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP FOUR FIFTY OR MOVING
ON IN HIS GARAGE SO AS BFORE
FIFTY EIGHT PESTICIDES AS THEIR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
PROPOSITION.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
WE'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
SO I ALWAYS WONDER WHY EVERYBODY
SITS ON THAT SIDE OF THE GOING
TO TESTIFY ON THAT SIDE.
ALIVE SHOES BUT ANYWAY GO AHEAD.
THEY CAN RECOMMEND ANY VIDEO ONE
WITH THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS WE ACTUALLY A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND OF COURSE NINE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY FILE NO FILE NO FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS THAT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE.
FIFTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
SP FIVE TWENTY NINE MR ROGER ONE
TENANT ASSOCIATIONS.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT.
COME ON UP.
I MEAN RUBIO RESEARCHER WITHOUT
THE RIGHTS COMMITTEE ON SAM'S
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL WOULD
NOT -- COST ANY MONEY AND I
WOULD SAY OUR OPPOSITION NOT A
SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAS GONE TO
ANY RED BOARD HEARING THE HELP
IS HERE AT THE HOUSING RIGHTS.
ISSUES WITH TENANTS.
I'M AUDREY MARTINEZ AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT -- FIVE TWENTY NINE
AND IT WON'T COST ANY MONEY AND
I'M GONNA TRANSLATE FOR THIS
NEXT TO ITEM.
KEEP COMING UP.
NUMBER THE LAWRENCE IS THE UP
FOR YOUR APPLE US SIX THINK OF A
SINGLE EIGHTEEN WITH -- MY NAME
IS DELORES AND I DO SO
[inaudible]
FOR FIVE TWENTY NINE HE COME --
SINCE YOU'RE HEDGING RIDGE
COMMUNITY -- ZERO THREE NO
FISCAL IMPACT REMAINS STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALL THIS IS ON THE LINE WITH
HOUSING RIGHTS COMMITTEE IS SAM
CISCO I FULLY FULLY SUPPORT.
I IT'S NOT GONNA HAVE ANY
PHYSICAL IMPACT THANK.
GENYA CASSIDY I'M A TENANT IN
ALAMEDA WITH ALAMEDA RENTERS
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT FROM
A LOT OF US HAVE HAD TO ORGANIZE.
IN OUR APARTMENTS THIS WILL HELP
A LOT OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
STEAK HOUSE -- ROBERT COOK THE
SECOND ATTENTION THIS MIGHT BE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE CANNOT BILL
WE GOT.
KEITH ROWLEY SAM CISCO HOUSING
RIGHTS COMMITTEE AND THE FULL
SUPPORT SENATOR.
FIVE TWENTY NINE THANKS LESTER
I'M SECTIONS CO TENANT HOW WITH
THE HOUSING RIGHTS COMMITTEE
INTENSE TOGETHER I'M FULL
SUPPORT THIS BILL WON'T COST ANY
EXTRA MONEY THIS HELP LAW.
A LOT OF TEN SOUNDS THE HOUSE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE -- ICE
FULLY SUPPORT BY.
TWENTY NINE HE SAID NO. TO FOR
TENANT AND LANDLORD [inaudible]
TO TO BE HAVING A GOOD FAITH.
AND EVEN NOT COST ANY MONEY AND
I US.
THIS COMMITTEE TO APPROVE IT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JEAN I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT BY.
TWENTY NINE HI BRETT HEARN
ALAMEDA TENANT WITH HOUSING
RIGHTS COMMITTEE SAN FRANCISCO --
I FULLY SUPPORT FIVE TO NINE AND
WILL HAVE NO FISCAL IMPACT
WHATSOEVER THANK YOU.
HI AMANDA MY BOND WITH THE
HOUSING RIGHTS COMMITTEE AND I
FULLY SUPPORT SP.
FIVE TO NINE AND IT WILL NOT.
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON MONEY THANK
YOU.
I LOOK BETTER KNOWN AS A KID A
DIRECTOR OF A TENNIS TOGETHER
FORGIVE MY VOICE -- WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT AS BEFORE
TWENTY NINE IT WILL NOT HAVE ANY
FISCAL IMPACT WE URGE YOU TO NOT
PUT THIS.
BILL INTO THIS IT'S A SPENCE
THANK YOU.
HI SHANTI SAYING TENTS TOGETHER
AND STEERING COMMITTEE YESTER
FORCIBLE HOUSING BAY AREA --
JUST ON BEHALF OF BROAD
COLLISION ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING I'LL BE QUICK -- HOME
STATE WHY CALIFORNIA C. R. U.
AFL-CIO STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA
UNITE HERE AFL-CIO CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION PUBLIC COUNCIL
COALITION FOR ECONOMIC SURVIVAL
NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP.
WALK ON THE SHIN OF SILICON
VALLEY CLERGY LADY UNITED FOR
JUSTICE AND DOZENS MORE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS ROOTED IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE SUPPORT AS BE FIVE TWENTY
NINE IT WILL SAVE MONEY NOT
SPEND IT. TWO SEVEN CONVOYS TEAR
THE HUMAN RELATIONS COMMISSION
FOR THE CITY OF FREMONT
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES IN THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THE WORST PROTECTIONS
FOR RENTERS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATE
BELLAMY HALF THE CALIFORNIA
METAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION.
BRIAN KINKS IN REPRESENTING A
THREE SAME REGIONAL APARTMENT
ASSOCIATIONS TODAY APARTMENT SO
SHE ASIAN ORANGE COUNTY EAST BAY
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
AND APARTMENT SO SHE'S IN
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE FINANCE NO FILE NO
FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
S. B. FIVE TWENTY NINE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AS TO BE SEVEN FORTY
NINE MS DRAWS -- CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION THE FILE.
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SEVEN FORTY NINE
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP -- SEVEN
FIFTY SIX ON CHARTER SCHOOLS IS
THEIR SUPPORT.
IS YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANKS FOR EVERYBODY WHO'S NOT
COME BEFORE SHAPE THE INPUT.
BE SAFE GOING HOME IS THEIR
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AT OKAY ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS SCHOOLS
SOCIALIZATION AND OPPOSITION.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JEFF RICE REPRESENTING THE A
PLUS PERSONALIZED LEARNING
NETWORK ASSOCIATION WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IS THERE A
FILE THE FILE NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO AT IS CAL
JOHNNY'S BILLS SP -- FOUR FIFTY
NINE CRIMES RATE GREAT BODILY
INJURY IS THEIR SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE YOU
KNOW FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
FOUR FIFTY NINE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP SIX TWENTY SEVEN ON
CANNABIS.
IS THERE SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
SIR FILE THE FILE NO FINAL KNOW
QUESTIONS WITHOUT.
OBJECTION SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP SEVEN OH
SIX ON PULMONARY HYPERTENSION
TASK.
THEIR SUPPORT.
STOP INCISION THE FILE AND
THERE'S NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
SEVEN OH SIX WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE AS BE SEVEN SIXTY THREE
ON TAXES FEDERAL DISASTER AREAS
IS THEIR SUPPORT.
IS ROB POSITION THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN SIXTY
THREE WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE AS B. --
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT IS THERE ARE
SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION SIR FILE A FILE.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP SEVEN SEVEN ZERO WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION
MISTER WHITE COUNT SKI HAS SP.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN QUALIFIED
EDUCATION LOANS SIR SPPORT SIR
OPPOSITION THE FILE NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP SIX OH THREE MISTER
BORCHERS HAS INDEPENDENT
TELEPHONE CORPORATIONS.
AS THEIR SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION IS THERE A
FILE FILE NO FILE THAT OBJECTION
SP SIX OH THREE WE GOT A
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
SIX FIFTY NINE ON C. QUOTE
TOURNEY FEES IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN YOU
DON'T EAT AROUND THE CITY
COUNCIL LABORS AND POSITION.
IN OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SIX FIVE NINE WITH THE
SUSPENSE.
SP SIX TWENTY FOUR BY MISTER
WELK ON QUALIFIED MEDICAL
SUPPLIES PROVIDERS IS THERE
SUPPORT.
AS THEIR OPPOSITION IS THERE A
FILE FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP SIX TWENTY
FOUR WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
SP SIX FIFTY THREE BY MISS CHANG
ON DENTAL HYGIENISTS SCOPE OF
PRACTICE.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE FILE YOU KNOW
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
SP SIX FIFTY THREE WERE SUSPENSE
SP SIX EIGHTY THREE BY MS GROVE
ON REGIONAL CENTERS AS THEIR
SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION.
DESERT THERE IS -- FILE NUMBER
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP SIXTY THREE WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE THAT CONCLUDES
OUR REGULAR ORDER OF BUSINESS.
WE HAVE ONE SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS I'M GONNA TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK.
AND WE WILL COME BACK IN FIVE
MINUTES AND HERE S. B. TWO
SEVENTY SIX I'LL GIVE TIME FOR
EVERYONE TO GET ORGANIZED.
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW -- MISS
DOCTOR PAN HAS WAVE PRESENTATION
WE'RE GONNA ALLOW THE PROPONENTS.
IN TOTAL -- THE PRIMER SPEAKERS
EIGHT MINUTES AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THE OPPONENTS.
PRIMARY SPEAKERS EIGHT MINUTES
AND THEN AT THE CONCLUSION OF
EIGHT MINUTES ON EACH SIDE
EVERYONE ELSE WILL BE CONFINED.
TO NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY TO FOCUS ON THE FISCAL
IMPACTS WILL BE BACK IN FIVE
MINUTES
OUR SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS.
ESPY. TWO SEVENTY SIX FOR DOCTOR
PAN HAD HE HAS WAY PRESENTATIONS.
BUT IN KEEPING WITH COMMITTEE
POLICY WE WILL ALLOW.
TESTIMONY ON BILLS WHEN.
BOTH FOR AND AGAINST.
WHEN -- FATHER'S WEIGHT.
TEST MONEY WE'RE GONNA DO
SOMETHING.
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS ISSUE.
WE ARE GOING TO HOLD ON ONE
SECOND.
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
SO THE PRIMARY SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
WE'RE GONNA GIVE THEM EIGHT
MINUTES IN TOTAL.
AND THE PRIMARY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
THEM. EIGHT MINUTES IN TOTAL.
AND THEN ANYONE AFTER THAT --
WOULD BE CONFINED TO THE AS YOU
HEARD ALL MORNING PEOPLE JUST
STATE THEIR ORGANIZATION.
AND THEIR POSITION.
I WOULD HOPE PEOPLE WOULD FOCUS
ON THE FISCAL IMPACTS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
ABOUT.
SO PLEASE TRY TO STAY ON THE
FISCAL IMPACTS.
AND WITH THAT.
WE WILL PROCEED WITH TEM -- SP
TWO SEVENTY SIX IS THERE ANYONE
WHO IS HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX COME ON UP.
CAN COME UP HERE THE PRIMARY
SPEAK WHAT'S UP TO YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA BE THERE OKAY FINE.
ALL RIGHT I WILL START THE CLOCK.
A LADY ONE NINE WE ARE THE COAST
OF WITH THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS WE ACTUALLY ABOUT ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL --
CLEARLY I THINK WE WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A NOT ONLY A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE BUT ALSO A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE.
AND THE COST -- FOR THE ILLNESS
OF THE CHILDREN THE LOST OF A
TIME FROM WORK FOR WITH PARENTS.
AS WELL AS THE TRACKING OF THE
POTENTIAL.
EXPOSURES TO ANYBODY THAT HAS
ANY THE E..
R. IT HAS BEEN EXPOSED TO
SOMEONE WITH MEASLES IS
EXORBITANT ACCORDING TO YOUR
ANALYSIS IT STARTS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN NINE AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR YOUR ONE THEN KIND
OF GOES UP AND THEN.
REDUCES OVER THE TIME.
HOW DO YOU PUT A PRICE ON?
HOSPITALIZATION FOR CHILD AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SOME OF THE
MORBIDITY THAT DOG AND MORTALITY
THAT MAY RESULT AS OF OF HAVING
OUR EXPOSURE AND OR HAVING THE
DISEASE ITSELF.
IN SO.
AS PUBLIC HEALTH PROVIDERS WE
CERTAINLY ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF MAKING SURE THAT TOM THIS IS
A NEW PROCESS THAT WILL START TO
ADDRESS.
THE EXORBITANT INCREASE IN TERMS
OF OF THE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ALIGN
WITH THE CDC LISTING OF
EXEMPTIONS AND SO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
AND HOPEFULLY THIS WILL WILL BE
MOVING ON TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
TALK TO SO YOU CON FELLOW AT THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE WITH SENATOR PAN AND
OTHERS.
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS OF I ALSO
WAS ACTUALLY AN INTERN IN
TRAINING RESIDENT IN LOS ANGELES
AT THE TIME OF THE TWELVE
THOUSAND PATIENT MEASLES
EPIDEMIC.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT DO THE
FACT THAT IT IS SO CONTAGIOUS
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
IMAGINE.
THE FISCAL COST OF AN ACTUAL
EPIDEMIC COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ONLY AT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SOMETHING CASES
ALTHOUGH THAT IS THE LARGEST
NUMBER WE'VE SEEN IN A LONG TIME.
THE ANTICIPATED ANTICIPATION OF
WHAT AN OUT BREAK AN EPIDEMIC
OUTBREAK WOULD COST US ACTUALLY
TOWARDS THE TYPES OF ESTIMATES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW
IN ORDER TO RUN THE DATABASE
XTERRA.
YOU DON'T SEE PHYSICIANS
STANDING FOR THE LEGISLATOR
APPROVING REGULATION OF US VERY
OFTEN BUT THAT'S HOW COMPELLING
THIS CASES AS A NO CLUE OF WHAT
HAPPENED THREE YEARS AGO WHEN WE
GOT RID OF THE PERSONAL BELIEF
EXEMPTION.
AND UP YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TRIPLED IN
THE NUMBER OF THEM THAT TURNED
OUT TO BE FRAUDULENT ALSO TURNED
OUT TO BE QUITE HIGH.
SO FOR ONCE YOU'RE SEEING A
CHANGE IN THE ATTITUDE OF THE
POSITIONS -- THAT FEEL THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED THE HELP OF THE
LEGISLATOR.
LEGISLATOR TO HELP US DEAL WITH
THIS PROBLEM.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
I ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION -- WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO OTHER SUPPORTERS -- IS
THERE FOLKS ARE THERE FOLKS HERE
IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
YOUR PRIMARY SPEAKERS CAN TAKE
THE CHAIRS AND THEN EVERYONE
ELSE CAN LINE UP.
AT THE MICROPHONE.
AND AGAIN I'M GONNA RESET THIS.
AND YOU HAVE A TOTAL.
OF EIGHT MINUTES FOR YOUR TWO
PRIMARY SPEAKERS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE START.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHANNON
THOMPSON AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF EDUCATE ADVOCATE.
I WANT TO EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION FOR GRANTING US
AMPLE TIME TO ADDRESS THE DATA.
PROVIDED IN OUR FISCAL REPORT
THE MEMBERS OF ALL BEEN PROVIDED
WITH AN ELECTRONIC IN A PHYSICAL
COPY OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
REPORT PREPARED BY EDUCATE
ADVOCATE AND I REFER YOU TO THE
SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL DETAIL
REGARDING THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
SP.
TWO SEVEN SIX AS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SERVING STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS WE URGE YOU TO MOVE THIS
BILL TO SUSPENSE TODAY AND VOTE
THAT IT REMAIN IN SUSPENSE WHEN
IT COMES TO YOUR ATTENTION LATER
THIS WEEK.
ESPY TWO SEVEN SIX PURPORTS TO
PROVIDE A SOLUTION TO THE
APPARENT INCREASE IN MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND CURRENT MEASLES
OUTBREAK BY ADVOCATING A
PHYSICIAN'S DISCRETION TO ISSUE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
INSTEAD ENTRUSTING A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER TO ASCERTAIN
ELIGIBILITY BY COMPARING A
STANDARDIZED REQUEST FORM
AGAINST NARROWLY CONSTRUED CDC
CONTRA INDICATIONS OF
PRECAUTIONS.
A PROCESS VOID OF ANY PHYSICAL
EXAM OR MEDICAL RECORD REVIEW OF
THE PATIENT.
IN OUR ANALYSIS OF THE FISCAL
IMPACT AS B. TWO SEVEN SIX IN
PARTS OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE MUST DETERMINE THE COGENT SEE
OF THE BROAD POINTED ISSUE AND
MEASURE THE FINANCIAL EXPOSURE
RELATIVE TO COMMENSURATE BENEFIT.
THE BILL PROPOSES EXORBITANT
SOLUTIONS INCLUDING A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION DATABASE WHICH
REQUIRES A VARIED LANDSCAPE OF
END USERS FROM SCHOOLS TO
PHYSICIANS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS.
AS WELL AS RETENTION OF MEDICAL
RECORDS WHICH CONTAIN PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE HEALTH INFORMATION
OF PATIENTS AND STUDENTS.
THUS IMPARTS A COMPLEX AND
COSTLY LAYER OF LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE ADHERENCE
TO HIPPA FOR BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT AS WELL AS
VARIOUS CIVIL RIGHTS IN
EDUCATION LAWS SUCH AS THE ADA
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
THE FEDERAL ID E. A AND THE
REHABILITATION ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE WE ESTIMATE THE
IMMEDIATE COST OF THE DATABASE
TO BE NINE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
THIS INITIAL COSTS.
OF CREATION IMPLEMENTATION
MAINTENANCE RETENTION OF
PERSONAL HEALTH RECORDS AND
PERSONNEL.
AS WELL AS AN UNKNOWN COST
ATTRIBUTED TO CD PH ATTORNEYS
PROMULGATING REGULATIONS AND
APPEALS.
OF ADDITIONAL IMPORTANCE IS THE
UNKNOWN COST TO OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO THE EXTENT THAT
STUDENT ENROLLMENT CONTINUES TO
DECLINE AND LITIGATION BASED ON
PATIENT.-AND STUDENT CONFIDENTIALITY AND
DISCRIMINATION ARE SUCCESSFULLY
BROUGHT FORTH.
THESE CASES CAN COST DISTRICTS
IN UPWARDS OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND
TO ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CASE WHICH
CAN INCLUDE COMPENSATORY DAMAGES
AND ATTORNEY'S FEES.
IN RESTRICTING THE CRITERIA OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WE CAN
ANTICIPATE A PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS WHO WILL BE EXCLUDED
FROM ATTENDANCE IMPACTING THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE REVENUE
TO THE UPWARDS OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR.
THIS IS A DECREASE IN FUNDS THAT
ARE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA CANNOT COMPENSATE.
FOR WE ARE ALREADY GRAPPLING
WITH YOUR AFTER YOUR DECLINING
ENROLLMENT PUTTING DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHTS MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
INDEED WE CAN LOOK TO SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AS
AN EXAMPLE OF THE POOR PHYSICAL
HEALTH AND DECLINING ENROLLMENT
OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS A SENATOR
PENN HAS NOTED HIS APRIL TENTH%
MAILING.
INDICATING THAT THE DISTRICT IS
AN IMMEDIATE RISK OF STATE
TAKEOVER.
GOVERNOR NEW SINCE JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL RECOMMENDS A 15%
DIVERSION HEALTH REALIGNMENT
FUNDING TO SUPPORT HIS
INITIATIVES WHICH TRANSLATES TO
A 50% CUT IN REALIGNMENT SUPPORT
TO PUBLIC HEALTH FOR SOME
COUNTIES INCLUDING SACRAMENTO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GENERAL FINE DECREASED 4% IN THE
LAST YEAR AND SAW EXCESS CUTS TO
LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS IN
UPWARDS OF 77%.
AS SENATOR PENN HIGHLIGHTS THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH TREATING
ADULTS ACQUIRING MEASLES THIRTY
THREE OF THE CURRENT FORTY FOUR
INFECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ADULTS AGE EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
OLDER.
WE ARE EMPLOYED TO COMPARE THE
CURRENT OUTBREAK COSTS AND
BUDGETARY DECLINE RELATIVE TO
PHYSICAL REQUIREMENTS ESPY TWO
SEVEN SIX ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE HAVE
BEEN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO PHYSICIANS
POTENTIALLY WRITING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS RESULTING IN A SINGLE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION NOT RELATED
TO MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS BUT A
PERSONAL OPINION LETTER WRITTEN
BY A PHYSICIAN. FOR PATIENT
INVOLVED IN A CUSTODY DISPUTE.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO ALLOW THE
RED HERRING A FRAUDULENT
EXEMPTIONS TO EXERT FINANCIAL
PRESSURE ON OUR STATE MEDICAL
BOARD RESOURCES.
I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
THE EXTENSIVE FINANCIAL
IMPLICATION OF SP TWO SEVEN SIX
TO OUR STATE DEPARTMENT AND
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
AND MOVED TO PROHIBIT SP TWO
SEVEN SIX FROM BECOMING THE
RUBICON FOR CUP COSTLY PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICY.
I ASK THIS ON BEHALF OF THE LESS
THAN 1% OF ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WHO HAVE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
MANY OF WHOM ARE ON DELAYED
IMMUNIZATION SCHEDULES HOW
POSITIVE SEROLOGICAL TIGHTER
RESULTS CONFERRING IMMUNITY AND
TEMPORARY EXEMPTIONS FROM LIVE
VIRUS VACCINES SUCH AS THE MMR
DUE TO IMMUNE SUPPRESSIVE
MEDICATION OR TREATMENTS.
IN CLOSING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU MOVE THIS EXORBITANT
DELTA SUSPENSE TODAY.
AND IT WHEN IT COMES BEFORE YOU
LATER THIS WEEK YOU AGAIN VOTE
TO RETAIN IN THE SUSPENSE FILE
THANK YOU. THREE MINUTES LEFT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER BRIGANTINE
ANOTHER MEMBERS OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OUTSIDE.
THEIR PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S KRISTINA HILDEBRAND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A VOICE
BETRAYS ADVOCACY.
WE AGREE WITH THE OLD MISS
THOMPSON JUST STATED REGARDING
SP TWO SEVEN SIX THIS BILL WILL
HAVE A LARGE UNNECESSARY AND
ONGOING.
IMPACT ON THE CALIFORNIA GENERAL
FUND -- WE'VE PROVIDED EACH OF
YOU AND THE COMMITTEE ARE AT
REPORT A VOICE BETRAYS ADVOCACY
ESTIMATES THE COST OF S. B. TWO
SEVEN SIX IN EXCESS OF FORTY
MILLION IN THE FIRST YEAR AND IN
EXCESS OF THIRTY TWO MILLION AND
EACH SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
WITH AN ADDITIONAL APPROXIMATELY
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
POTENTIAL LOSS AND SCHOOL ADA
AND OR MILLIONS IF NOT BILLIONS
IN POTENTIAL HEALTH CARE COSTS.
THIS IS ALL TO DEAL WITH A VERY
SMALL NUMBER BUT UNKNOWN NUMBER
OF FAKE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
IT DOES NOT MAKE FISCAL SENSE TO
SPEND. TO SPEND NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
CALIFORNIA GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
ON THIS BILL TO GO AFTER AN
EXTREMELY NO SMALL NUMBER OF
PHYSICIANS WHEN THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD HAS THE TOOLS TO
DO SO.
AND IN DOING SO UNDERMINING THE
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP FOR
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS IN THE STATE.
ANOTHER STATED GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS TO REDUCE THE POCKETS WHERE
HAD IMMUNITY OR COMMUNITY
IMMUNITY IS NOT REACHED IN
CERTAIN SCHOOLS.
THAT IS WHERE VACCINATIONS DO
NOT REACH 95% THIS BILL WILL NOT
ADDRESS THAT AS THE MAJORITY OF
SCHOOLS THAT FALL BELOW 95%.
DO SO BECAUSE OF MEDIC DIDN'T DO
SO BECAUSE OF MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
BUT BECAUSE CHILDREN ARE OVERDUE
WITH THAT VACCINATIONS OR
CONDITIONALLY ENTERED.
IN OTHER WORDS THEY'RE GETTING
VACCINATED APPROXIMATELY 20% OF
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS ARE
EITHER TEMPORARY BECAUSE OF
POSITIVE TITERS OR IMMUNE
SUPPRESSIVE TREATMENTS AND
THEREFORE THIS BILL DOES NOT
ADDRESS THAT AND THE FISCAL
IMPACT IS HUGE.
FOR NOT A VERY AN EVEN SMALLER
NUMBER OF MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
A FEW OTHER AREAS WHICH ARE OF
CONCERN TO US WHICH MISS
THOMPSON DID NOT TOUCH ON INTO
THE UNKNOWN THE HIGH COSTS OF
THE APPEALS PROCESS.
ANOTHER AREA INCLUDES THE COST
OF OUTREACH TO PHYSICIANS TO
SCHOOLS AND OTHER INTERESTED
PARTIES AND FINALLY AS WE
MENTIONED IN OUR FISCAL ANALYSIS
OF THE BILL C. PH WILL NEED TO
ACQUIRE LIABILITY INSURANCE OR
ESTABLISH SOME FORM OF
COMPENSATION FUND. FOR ANY
VACCINE INJURY RESULTING IN
THEIR DENYING A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION NEITHER THE VACCINE
MANUFACTURERS NOR THOSE
ADMINISTERING VACCINES ARE
LIABLE FOR VACCINE INJURY UNDER
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
CHILDREN'S VACCINE INJURY
COMPENSATION ACT.
HOWEVER IF CD PH DENIES A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION AND
SUBSEQUENTLY THAT CHILD IS
VACCINATED IN ORDER TO ASCEND.
ATTEND SCHOOL AND SUFFERS FROM A
SEVERE ADVERSE REACTION THE
PARENTS COULD SUE CD PH FOR
VACCINE INJURY DUE TO FORCED
VACCINATION.
THE MEASLES OUTBREAK IN RECENT
YEARS INCLUDE THE INCLUDING
THOSE HAPPENING CURRENTLY N
CALIFORNIA HAVE ONLY BEEN IN 25%
OF SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT.
IMPACT.
THE MEASLES EPIDEMIC OR THE
FISCAL PIECE OF THE MEASLES
EPIDEMIC BECAUSE IT'S NOT BEING
TRANSMITTED IN SCHOOL IN THE
DISNEY LAND TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN THERE ARE TWENTY FOUR
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AND NONE OF
THEM WERE TRIMMED TRANSMITTED IN
SCHOOL -- TREATMENT MARKET AT
THE TIME CAN I JUST FINISH UP.
PATRICE ABBASI FEELS THIS BILL
IS UNNECESSARY AND WE ASK THAT
YOU RESPECTFULLY MOVE THIS
COSTLY BILL TO SUSPENSE TODAY
AND WHEN IT COMES FOR A VOTE
LATER INTHE WEEK PLEASE KEEP IN
SUSPENSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO EVERYONE ELSE WHO'S
LINED UP PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOUR POSITION.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND JOSH WILL COLEMAN FROM
ROSEVILLE AND I VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LISA JENKINS FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M WITH A ON PARENTS
UNITED FOR KIDS A CITIZEN
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING
CONSIDERATION OF THE FULL FISCAL
IMPACT TODAY -- AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT THEY'RE REALLY GOING
TO BE A LOT OF PEOPLE MOVING OUT
OF STATE BASED ON BILLS LIKE
THIS I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
CONSIDER THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
POINTS THAT WERE BROUGHT BY THE
LADIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHANNON PRIMER ON BEHALF OF
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND MY CLIENTS
IN FIVE DIFFERET SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO -- AND I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING THREE HUNDRED
MILITARY SPOUSES WHO CANNOT
TRAVEL HERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SMALL CHILDREN OR THEIR HUSBANDS
ARE DEPLOYED -- AND WE ALL
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
OLIVIA CAN YOUR ROSEVILLE
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS WENDY KATY I'M FROM
LINCOLN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI TARA THORTON WITH OUR KIDS
OUR CHOICE IN ON BEHALF OF THE
FOURTEEN THOUSAND I'M CONCERNED
PARENTS IN OUR GROUP WE ASK YOU
TO OPPOSE OR WE OPPOSE BUT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING ON TIME AND CLARITY ON
THE FISCAL IMPACTS.
AND TO CONSIDER THE ALL THE CAKE
CUT COSTS TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
DANNY SMITH NUTRITIONAL THERAPY
PRACTITIONER -- RESIDENT OF
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND I'M CONCERNED DEEPLY
ABOUT THE IMPACT.
THANK YOU.
CURRY ALAN HAMMER WEST
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE HERE TO
ADD THEIR VOICE.
SEEING NONE FINANCE NO FILE NO
FILE ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE BOTH FOR AND
AGAINST THEM WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SP TWO SEVENTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR SPECIAL
ORDER BUSINESS THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED